MOTHBALLED, BOTH OF THEM, AND
$90 MILLION ON LIGHT BULB
VENTURES.
IT’S NOT YOUR JOB.
MEANWHILE CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM IS
ACTUALLY TRYING TO GET
75 MILLION IN TAX DOLLARS, YOUR
DOLLARS, AND CALIFORNIA DIRECTLY
TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
JUDICIAL WATCH IS NOW SUING TO
BLOCK THAT PROGRAM.
McCONNELL IS VERY TO PUT
BRAKES ON NANCY PELOSI’S INSANE
STATE BAILOUTS.
HERE WITH MORE IS LOUISIANA
SENATOR, OUR FRIEND
JOHN KENNEDY.
SENATOR, LISTEN, I’M SPEAKING
OUT AGAINST MYSELF BECAUSE I AM
UNFORTUNATELY, I AM TIED TO
NEW YORK BECAUSE OF THIS JOB.
OTHERWISE, I WOULD LIVE THERE
WITH YOU.
YOU’RE IN FLORIDA OR IN TEXAS.
BUT I’M HERE.
IT’S GOING TO COST MONEY BUT
WHAT’S FAIR IS FAIR.
NEW YORK, WELL, THEY LIKE THE
DUMBEST PEOPLE THAT SPEND ALL OF
THE MONEY IN TAXES TO DEATH.
LOUISIANA ENDS SHOULD NOT BE
FORCED TO PAY FOR THAT.
>> NO, WE SHOULDN’T.
I THINK WHAT THE GOVERNOR CUOMO
FORGETS IS HOW MUCH MONEY WE’VE
GIVEN THE STATES ALREADY.
MY STATE HAS RECEIVED ABOUT
$2.5 BILLION ALREADY.
I DON’T KNOW HOW MANY BILLIONS
NEW YORK HAS RECEIVED.
THAT MAY NOT BE AS MUCH AS THE
GOVERNOR WANTS, BUT IT’S NOT
LIBERAL EITHER.
OUR POSITION ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE OF THE CITY IS, LOOK, WE
SPENT $3 TRILLION.
A LOT OF THAT DID GO TO STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THAT’S A STEP, LET’S SEE HOW IT
WORKS.
ONCE THE ECONOMY STARTS TO OPEN
UP AGAIN, LET’S SEE WHAT THE
REVENUES GO UP.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A SHARED
SACRIFICE.
STATES AND CITIES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO PAIR THEIR BUDGET, JUST
LIKE PEOPLE HAVE.
NOW, SPEAKER PELOSI, SHE WANTS
TO SPEND IT -- WASTE A TRILLION
DOLLARS.
I WOULDN’T BE SURPRISED IF SHE’S
WORKING ON A STIMULUS PACKAGE
FOR THE MURDERING HORNET.
SHE HAS NO CONCEPT OF DEFICITS.
THIS IS NOT LOUISIANA DISHWATER
WE ARE SPENDING.
THIS IS TAXPAYER MONEY AND WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY IT BACK
AND ALL WE’RE SAYING SAYING IS,
LET’S GO SLOWLY AND SEE WHAT
WORKS AND WHAT DOESN’T WORK.
>> Sean: I THINK, SENATOR,
MAYBE SHE SHOULD LEAVE THAT
GATED COMMUNITY AND THAT
BEAUTIFUL MANSION WITH ALL THE
ICE CREAM AND EVEN THE FREEZER,
GET ON HER PRIVATE JET, MAKE A
BIG CARBON FOOTPRINT AND GET
BACK TO WORK LIKE THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY, AND ALL THE P/E,
MASKS SHE NEEDS, WHATEVER, SHALL
BE TAKEN CARE OF LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE, BUT GET TO WORK.
BUT THEY WANT TO USE THIS, THEIR
UNFUNDED PENSIONS, AND THEIR
DEFICITS, AND THEIR DEBT.
ALL OF THESE ARE HIGH TAX STATES
THAT WASTE, FRAUD, AND ABUSE.
IF IT’S NOT COVID-19, MY ANSWER
IS NO DEAL.
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
HELP WORKERS, SMALL BUSINESSES,
HEALTH WORKERS, AND GET THE
COUNTRY BACK OPEN.
THAT’S IT.
I THINK THAT’S MORE THAN FAIR.
>> I INTRODUCED A BILL TODAY TO
GIVE THE STATES MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO SPEND THE MONEY THAT WE’VE
ALREADY GIVEN THEM, AND WE’VE
ALREADY GIVEN THEM AT LEAST 200,
$250 BILLION.
BUT THAT DOESN’T MEAN THE MONEY
SHOULD BE WASTED.
IT SHOULDN’T BE WASTED ON
BAILING OUT MISMANAGED PENSION
PLANS.
IT SHOULDN’T BE SPENT ON PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN OUR COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
ILLEGALLY.
I UNDERSTAND WHERE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS COMING FROM.
HE JUST THINKS THE BORDER IS A
NUISANCE.
HE THINKS THAT IF YOU BELIEVE IN
IMMIGRATION LAWS, YOU ARE A
RACIST.
I DON’T THINK THAT VETTING
PEOPLE PROPERLY BEFORE THEY COME
INTO YOUR COUNTRY IS RACIST.
I THINK IT’S PRUDENT IN THE
WORLD WE LIVE IN.
WE SHOULDN’T BAIL OUT THAT KIND
OF NONSENSE.
AND I WOULD POINT OUT AGAIN,
WE’VE ALREADY GIVEN THE STATES
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY.
>> Sean: A TON.
BY THE WAY, CAN I POINT OUT,
SENATOR, AND WE ALWAYS
APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON THE
PROGRAM, BY THE LOOKS OF THE
BACKGROUND I WOULD SAY YOU ARE
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., IS THAT
TRUE?
>> I AM I AM.
>> Sean: YOUR WORKING?
ALL BUY ICE CREAM.
I WILL SEND IT.
THE EXPENSIVE KIND.
>> WE ARE BEING SMART, WE ARE
SOCIALLY DISTANCING, WE ARE
WEARING MASKS.
THERE IS A WAY TO SAVE LIVES AND
SAVE JOBS --
>> Sean: THANK YOU, SENATOR.
>> AND WE ARE GOING TO WORK